Michael so he say where the most amazing
crisp delicious fennel salad mackerel
it's incredible
cheap was so delicious as you fish a
just means basically marinating but the
secret is in the dressing been great for
take the top off and the bottom and
don't slice off too much to begin with
otherwise you'll regret it you'd be
knife nice and flat and just start
peeling twists you see how thick pith is
just follow with your knife nothing
worse when you're doing this it comes
out like a hexagon or 50 pence piece you
can do this dressing with lemons limes
oranges but there's something quite
beautiful about the pink grapefruit turn
it over and double check a little bit
they're really important to get rid all
the pith and slice each side of your
piff that keeps all those segments
together there's the line it's nice down
it's nice in
give that little stir whisk it and it
starts to separate all those little
segments season it olive oil
these are little fennel prawns amazing
flavor gives a really nice and seedy
delicious freshness
I've always frustrated me how many
people throw that away because flavor in
there is fantastic in a fish stock
incredibly everything great
next chopped coriander which we say is
served in his marinade something quite
picturesque when you see your work
listening save a little touch of your
dressing for the funnel now your macro
it's being fileted and pin bound rinse
your knife and just slice through
bite-sized chunks ceviche is popular in
Spain and South America is always made
from raw fish or seafood cured in a
citrus dressing the less you handle the
mackerel the better is when you start
mixing up and tossing and turning it you
lose the texture the fresh the mackerel
is the better will taste but when you're
serving it raw like this make sure it
really is fresh out of the sea just
lightly seasoned so that's Chevy say
starts the Cure and marinade and
mackerel finish that with thin little
shards of pink grapefruit and then just
a little drizzle of olive oil on top
leave that to sit I always like
marinating my mackerel glittery an hour
before I want to eat it that kind of
cured lightly pickled
ceviche flavor that is incredible to go
with my ceviche for my ultimate light
lunch a beautiful quinoa salad with
amazing textures and fresh aromatic
flavors to excite the palate
at one part pre-rinse quinoa to two
parts cold water if you're not using pre
rinse the quinoa grains should be soaked
before use to remove their bitter
coating bring to a simmer and cook for
about 20 minutes until the water is
absorbed
spring the cooked quinoa onto a plate
and spread out to cool meanwhile dry
roast straight almonds in a frying pan
once golden add raisins
chopped mint and spring onions
pihl's strips of skin from a whole
cucumber to make stripes then remove the
seeds and chop into Halfmoon slices
at half cherry tomatoes and the cold
quinoa
and gently mix in with your fingers
[Music]
season with salt and pepper a dress with
a good squeeze of lime and drizzle of
olive oil
finish with a few fresh mint leaves
and for my ultimate light lunch I'm
doing another delicious salad with
shaved fennel the secret here is to peel
the outside like this with a firm skin
it starts to sort of brighten up a
little bit almost like the sun's come
out once you've discarded the outer
layer gently shave off thin strips of
fennel for your salad the advantage of
having this nice and thin is because
it's like these wonderful thin fennel
crisps fragrant delicious peel them in
to your iced water this can be done
color of hours before you want to eat
this will preserve the phenols fresh
flavor and make it lovely and crisp
[Music]
drained the fennel look at that
beautiful complement the fennel and
delicious dressing
starting with chopped coriander fennel
and lime bringing you all together zest
over the fennel and then use all the
goodness inside the lime lightly
seasoned it dressed with the leftover
grapefruit marinade from the ceviche
followed by a drizzle of olive oil
a delicious mackerel sat marinating away
the beautiful stunning fennel salad
and that goes brilliantly well with a
quinoa packed full of flavor but
incredibly light and very healthy and
they wander on so thin
[Music]
Jesus salad is definitely a classic but
the trick to keeping dishes like this
modern and relevant is to tweak them but
not lose what made them brilliant in the
first place here's my version for the
ultimate American lunch my first twist
is in the dressing for me the most
important part of the Caesar salad is
that dressing rich creamy slightly spicy
begin by making a basic mayonnaise start
off with the egg yolks then just a
little spoon Dijon and then a little
splash of red wine vinegar start
whisking once we've got that nice
slightly thickened texture drizzle in
your olive oil should fall through your
whisk it's like a nice thick double
cream texture beautiful now take the
mayo to another level with anchovies and
crushed garlic now chop up the anchovies
and the garlic together
so I almost want that to be like a
really nice puree then grated parmesan
lemon juice that will make the dressing
citrusy lighter in color and then a
little splash of water in you know all
of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise and your amazing delicious
like dressing nice next job the croutons
and I like using crusty bread for extra
crunch I'll just dice up your bread
season with salt and pepper then add to
a hot pan with olive oil and fry give
that a really nice toss as the croutons
start to turn golden simply great on a
generous amount of Parmesan cheese
you've been rolling around stop them
from sticking together and give that
really nice cheesy delicious crouton and
now they're out now for the fun job
assembling the Caesar salad
starting with romaine lettuce and don't
slice the lettuce too thinly a squeeze
of lemon on with half of that gutsy
anchovy mayo dressing saving some to
coat your chicken later then sprinkle
half your croutons do that very nice mix
salad in it's all beautifully dressed
add the remaining croutons and finished
with a good grating of Parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect Caesar salad
however I'm gonna take it to another
level and grill a stunning chicken
breast start by preheating your griddle
pan then butterfly your chicken breast
simply slice from the thin end towards
the thick bit of the breast the knife do
the work and literally just open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and she asked nice and moist in
the center season the chicken on both
sides with salt and ground pepper lay
your chicken breasts onto the grill
never oil the grill and you were
absolutely ready to cook the chicken
[Music]
cooked for three to four minutes on each
side until chickens got those lovely
stripes from the griddle which adds a
gorgeous smoky flavor whilst they rest
spoon over some of the remaining and
tobi dressing the chicken cools down the
flavor the seasoning of the anchovy the
garlic and the parmesan seeps into that
chicken slice the chicken into strips
Wow I serve the chicken warm in a
separate bowl so it doesn't wilt the
salad spoon the dressing
finished out a little touch with
dressing an American classic
I think we're most popular sellers
anywhere in the world
but it's still the most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch this really is an
American Dreams roasted tomato soup
beautiful vine tomatoes the riper the
tomatoes the better this soup take the
core out get your thumb and place it
half a centimeter underneath the tip of
your knife place it in and then just
twist around that's the only part of the
smart oh that we're not using red onion
and garlic red onion because it's
sweeter and a white onion slice your
onions and your garlic it's nice and
fine traditionally we make it in a pot
it's so much better to start it off on
top of the stove searing the tomatoes
and the garlic but it goes in the oven
you actually roast those martyrs and
they don't stoop and it's a big
difference in flavor be quite generous
for the olive oil
it makes the soup nice and glossy shiny
salt pepper and then a little teaspoon
of cayenne just gives it that heat but
it's not as fierce as chili take your
tomatoes and just slice them in half and
then build such a sugar that's gonna
help intensify the sweetness a little
sprinkle of aged bottle of vinegar gives
that nice dark rich acidity to the soup
it's given 2025 minutes 180 to make my
soup even more irresistible I'm gonna
make a punchy sun-dried tomato pesto to
drizzle over the top now I'm making this
in a that's the mortar because you feel
so much more in control and you're not
depending on a blade that's whizzing
around at a thousand miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts toast of the absolute max and then
in smelling there is incredible parmesan
lightly grate there this is where it
starts to become creamy X version olive
oil doesn't need salt because the
parmesan is gonna season it for you and
just take a couple tablespoons of the
oil the sun-dried tomatoes where it
really helps to make that stunning pesto
I can smell those roasted tomatoes on
them out Wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes put your spoon through those
tomatoes they break up instantly bring
that up to the ball let it simmer for 3
or 4 minutes want to make it little more
creamy now cream in give that a little
stir you can keep it rustic and you get
your mash your in and you've got that
nice thick rich chunky tomato soup or do
yourself a stick blender
blitzen's like that you plead lays the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom mmm
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty I'm gonna
knock up a deliciously gutsy version of
cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup box rabbit
now so classic we'll make a roux 50
grams of butter three nice tablespoons
of flour that's all a roux is basically
traditionally you would use flour butter
and milk but it won't rabbit the milk is
often cheeky substituted for a stiff
slug of stout gives it that strong gutsy
flavor
on it nice take make sure those lumps
are out there nice teaspoon of Dijon
mustard and then season it nice and
spicy be moist issues sauce gives it
that delicious intrigue and flavor
now that smells amazing almost brings
tears to your eyes
beautiful now Welsh rabbit wouldn't be a
stunning Welsh rabbit without rich
mature cheese so and a great Montgomery
cheddar goes well with beer and top that
in really important to put this in or
the roof it's still nice and hot because
the cheese melts now for the bread I
prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
want that nice crisp base to mobile
forever so toast it both sides
[Music]
spread a beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture just great blister and bubble
and gratinéed
little splash lien parent and back under
the krill for 90 seconds in one
delicious creamy roasted tomato soup
it's coming back to me all those days I
had off school poster purpose the lie
about feeling ill just to get a bowl of
my mother's tomato soup how bad was that
but my god it was worth it whoa
now I'll wash rabbit yeah look at those
babies that just takes cheese on toast
to another level
Wow roast this creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious Welsh rabbit
I feel like wringing sick
[Music]
lightly fried my delicious halloumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables but
first I'm preparing a simple slow roast
tomato and watercress salad
these choice matters are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vitam are as
good or even just big normal plum
tomatoes lay the tomatoes on the tray
and he's going to the oven for about 90
minutes if you turn the oven down really
low you can leave them in overnight to
be almost longer you leave them the
better they taste
once you've season them with salt or
sprinkle over with some sugar and the
salt and sugar combined speeds up the
drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic slice then just
spread that on now the tray looks quite
full and compact but 90 minutes in
heaven you'll see everything shrink down
all the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes place your tomatoes into an
oven preheated to 150 degrees C and cook
long and slow for an hour and a half now
halloumi cakes there's something quite
exciting about halloumi cheese it's a
very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
kill the carrots great not too finely
you want that nice texture next
courgette
the secret is keeping all your grated
the same for that into a sieve a
sprinkling of salt will draw out liquid
from the vegetables then grate the
halloumi halloumi cheese doesn't look
that tasty but once you've got color on
it in the pan it's really really
delicious now really important to
squeeze out the excess water in the veg
you'll see all that water that needs to
come out of there if we didn't do this
you'll make your little patties non
fireball because the whole thing starts
to separate and then mix in with the
cheese it's pre millions chopped up the
whites under greens now we're gonna
season that with some delicious fresh
mint and fresh coriander whenever it's
vegetarian I like to put a combination
of herbs in there tarragon and parsley
mint to coriander basil and lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other next
two eggs in give that a little mix add
the eggs to the mixture and then finally
a couple of tablespoons of breadcrumbs
the Beckhams help dry out any excess
moisture
mix all the ingredients together before
you start shaping these taste the
mixture hmm it's really important to
identify the seasoning now if you wait
until you've cooked them they'll be too
late to adjust the seasoning roll them
to a large gulfport shake them it's like
a little mini burger
you could spice these up with some chili
in there I'm got fresh chili chili
flakes and it's something that can be
done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot
bossun waiting for that i'll get the
dressing ready slicer red chili seeds
and all on an angle into shards then
chopped fresh ginger seasoned with a
sprinkle of sugar and salt add some rice
wine vinegar add a couple of tablespoons
of olive oil to finish off some chopped
coriander
got a sweet sour spicy flavor with my
chili dressing done I can start frying
off my halloumi cakes in a hot oiled pan
and get a nice crisp edge
you already start to smell that sauteed
halloumi with the courgettes and carrots
smells delicious really important for a
nice amount of color on them as my cake
this is all the way I can finish off my
roast tomato salad one of my favorite
knees has to be watercress just cut off
stalks slop rings watercress dish a lot
they're brilliantly well together gosh a
lot looks so dainty when you open up
these little wing nuts don't forget to
turn your cakes now tomatoes whatever
you don't use just Jardin and put them
in the fridge you just drop those slow
cooked warm tomatoes over the watercress
the sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious little drizzle of age I'll
smooth vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress watercress is naturally
peppery so doesn't need any pepper just
little touch of salt and then a light
sprinkling of extra-virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready so important to
have taken out that water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate and
then just get your dressing take a spoon
of it and then tilt it to the side
because with the garnish I don't want
the juice that does not turn you on to
become a vegetarian for the knives I
honestly don't know what will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
more cress salad all of the flavor with
none of the meat